welcome everyone here good morning
and welcome to the yale
entrepreneurs and investors conference
my name is jimmy liu and i am a class of
1977
college and the chair of the uh alumni
association the aya
the organization that helped produce
this particular program
it's really heartwarming for me to see
such a large crowd
i've been doing adventure investing for
the last 20 years in the us and china
and technology and healthcare
and it's great to see such a large crowd
of
who are in the field of technology
entrepreneurs investors
folks who support and service of the
overall ecosystem
and
we've had a lot of
smaller i guess events focused on
technology topics in the past but there
was a growing demand to have a larger
event more comprehensive program
to focus on this topic and
here we are today so great menu
hopefully you'll have an opportunity to
meet each other
share insights and you can do
you know work out a few term scenes at
the same time
so
but um so i wanted to
mention that uh you know we focused on
the theme of
uh dale's ecosystem because we really
wanted to recognize the incredible
entrepreneurial spirit and energy on
campus and also sort of the global
community surrounding it
it's amazing to have folks from all
different professions here people with
different expertise coming together
to be able to
share thoughts during this particular
conference
i'd like to thank the yale clubs of
silicon valley um
san francisco and la for helping us put
this event together today
also i'd like to uh
thank the sponsors the key sponsors uh
without them we wouldn't be able to hold
this kind of event um sponsors include
goodman proctor the leading technology
law firm a firm that i actually used as
a
our series a
law firm investing in a company in
boston called irobot and that has been
very very successful
and then a good one was very very good
to us in terms of our representation
and then um cyber associates the
investment bank technology investment
bank that i'm sure will be able to take
advantage of going forward in your
various activities making
activities and then of course our very
own paper g that
started on the yale campus and
grew out and expanded and taken over the
world they have their headquarters here
in san francisco and i think they also
have offices in seattle and vancouver
i'd also like to single out
victor wong
who is leading the charge of ppg
for having the vision and the energy to
think about having a program like this
and
so
it's people like victor you know i got
an email late last night saying you have
to be here at 8 30. you've got you've
got like eight to ten minutes to do your
thing uh you've got a one sentence
introduction of our guests from
from yale so so as a board member of
portfolio companies i appreciate ceos
that can really take charge so thanks
vader for uh putting this thing together
so um let me uh then now talk about the
aya really quickly because
i think you know aya is the organization
that helped uh to support programs such
as this
and um we've really kind of transformed
in the last six or seven years
we did our first strategic plan ever in
2007
to see if we can go ahead and sort of
move away from just supporting
class reunions
social events happy hours
to
initiate programs that are much more
meaningful
and so we
have
content-rich programs like this
we have
certain programs that focus on service
and so it's a very important part of our
mission as alumni
to service our local communities and
also communities around the world we
have the alumni service
corps
that bring various
skill sets of alumni to the various
undisturbed sections of the world like
in africa helping
women entrepreneurs figure out a
business plan
going to china
to help teach basketball soccer skills
or to take care of health
related problems
in
dominican republic
so
you can participate in that it happens
several times a year in different
locations we've also had volunteer
leadership exchanges where
you know alumni
young alumni go to various countries to
meet with
their counterparts in
universities leading universities in
japan australia and other locations to
compare notes about alumni engagement
so
then we have the signature data service
which is actually going to take place
tomorrow may 10.
i'm actually going to be uh putting my
work clothes on and
cleaning up alleyways in chinatown
but we've had programs all over the
world where uh alumni
and we started this actually six years
ago and a lot of other universities are
following suit so it's nice to be able
to
get copied in that particular initiative
and so this year is actually going to be
pretty amazing because we were able to
get
as our honorary chairs of this year's
day of service u.s presidents 41
42
43
and possibly 45
honorary champions
so
go to youtube and
check out the personal videos of
georgia's worship and bill clinton talk
about yale and commitment to service
and what it means
to give back to the community
those are pretty inspirational videos
that you can check out
so
let me go ahead and move forward to
talk about how you can get engaged
you can talk to me you can talk to
several of the board members uh current
and former board members that i see in
the audience and talk to uh mickey mouse
uh
aya
staff member
about how you would like to get involved
with yale and with the
so i'm really looking forward to today's
program i think we can use this program
to really build upon it have the
opportunity for you each one of you to
meet each other and then to be able to
get to know each other better because i
think we as yellings share
a really unique bond and this
relationship that we have with each
other i think we can help each other
sort of achieve our personal goals going
forward
so um
without uh further ado let's uh get to
the program because uh we have two very
special guests
and uh maybe i can invite jim and kyle
on stage
to talk about the state of
entrepreneurship on campus
i'll first introduce jim i guess you
have a slide or two and you'd like to
show
jim
is a
an entrepreneur in his own right started
a a very successful company and uh he is
now the
director executive managing director of
the yale entrepreneurial institute
and he is there on campus mentoring
students
with new venture ideas and a lot of
groups have already
benefited from jim's
expert advice and guidance so jim
tell us what's going on um
thank you very much jimmy um
caliber would like to keep on that for a
minute um actually
now that you figure that out
uh thank you very much for uh for having
us here it's a it's an honor and
a privilege to be asked to be part of
this discussion uh
what we're doing at yale is
starting nascent new ventures
with
the students primarily
and for the last few years with with
faculty as well
um
and interestingly i could steal the
clip event
interestingly i i'd be remiss if i
started going through this presentation
about noting one one person in
particular
we uh we got started in the mid-2000s
2006 2007
when as many of you already know who are
either mentors or board members at fyi
in the room
um the wall street journal publishes an
article
about students in electronic student
ventures who weren't successful and came
back into the bay area and matt sanchez
who's the ceo of the company in his
moratorium you now set
was that entrepreneur
so here we are 10 years later
talking to you about what we're doing in
yale with
starting under dozens of student
ventures in response to the challenges
that this young guy faced on the campus
back in the mid-2000s so i think there's
some
some poetic justice to the fact that
we're back here to hit shop to talk
about entrepreneurship at yale
um
i'm going to describe i'm going to
describe for you what we do at the
university only insofar as for those of
you who are from out here in the bay
area are concerned
who are interested either in being
associated with what we do
mentors for what we do
investors for the ventures that are
coming out we're supporters of the
program we would love to have greater
involvement from the alumni community we
are not
faculty the people who run yeah we're
staff members we're business people
we're paid to start companies help get
them financed and help them hire
employees and be successful to the full
extent possible so we rely greatly upon
the alumni community in making all those
connections and getting those ventures
off the ground so we really think this
is a huge plus for us to be here today
what you're looking at is a picture of
the process we go through every summer
um over the course of the last seven
years we've essentially stitched
together a series of programs the summer
accelerator is probably the best known
part of yei because it's in that process
ten weeks of every summer yeah we
identify that the paper g's in the world
the sort of high-flying ventures that we
think have the greatest chance of
success
and help to accelerate them with the
help of our board members our advisory
council our mentors and helping to get
them to first financing
networking is extremely important you
would think that every yell student had
access to people who were
polished and
captains of industry but in fact that's
not the case so what we've found ever
since we first got started is having
exposure to people who actually are
further along in their careers is
extremely important for helping those
students get started so every year we'll
invite back people who who've built very
considerable
businesses to help talk to the students
about
about aspects of their businesses that
might be relevant to new startups
and we've been in existence so long now
that some of the fellows who graduated
from yeah
including victor long and guys like bob
casey pictured here they come back
and talk to students who are coming up
behind them about the successes and
challenges they have in starting
businesses
and
it's pretty typical to see when you have
a 25 or a 30 year old in the room
talking about the challenges that they
have there's a great deal of interest in
the part of the 20 and the 22 year olds
to figure out how they can use these
people as role models for their for
their for their own businesses
mentors are probably one of the most
important resources we have
um i think i speak for kyle as well as
for many of our board members when i say
that having access to people who have
particular domain expertise in the
businesses that we're trying to start is
essential we really can't do that on our
own as generalists we don't have enough
expertise for that so we're hoping that
in the fullness of time for those of you
who are interested in being more more
associated with the university that you
would consider being mentors to some of
the ventures as well
most recently and this came out
throughout a conversation that we had
with
scott faber who's some place in the room
and a handful of other alums here in
northern california last year we
realized that as a university we were a
little bit underserved in the sense that
we didn't have a large enough tech
community to help get our adventures off
the ground
so last year alina grips go my colleague
was someplace in the audience here
she built a sustainable corner uh
she piloted what was called a tech boot
camp so alongside this summer fellowship
every year now we also run a 10-week
technology incubator that teaches kids
the full web the full web stack and lets
them get their tech ventures their tech
ideas off the ground this year we're
doubling the size of the program and
we're hopeful that in years to come
we'll put scores if not hundreds of
students through this facility to help
create a technology layer on top of the
liberal arts milieu that yale is known
for
um
probably the
greatest surprise to us is the fact that
um no matter where you look
you find ideas i mean we're sitting on a
campus that has eleven thousand of the
smartest kids in the world
and four thousand of the sports faculty
and so
a few years ago we decided that in
addition to the summer fellowship we
would sprinkle small amounts of money on
the water every academic year through
something called the venture creation
program and here's how it works first of
every month you can come to us with an
idea and if you think the idea makes any
sense at all
we'll give you a couple thousand bucks
to try it
and this year alone we've had 90
different venture teams come to us
looking for support
so many teams that in fact we had to
outsource the responsibility for handing
out the money
um
kids in school of management they're
pretty smart so we said here's the money
you guys decide who to hand it out to so
these six people this year decided which
of the 59 teams uh which of the 89 teams
that came to us would get support and so
what we're finding now is
not just that we have people with
interesting ideas but that we also have
talent enough around us through students
faculty alumni or for the vcs and angels
behind them to make smarter more smarter
decisions on a larger larger scale so
we're very excited about this
and last but not least we were fortunate
enough this past year to start our own
our own fun very modest size three
million dollars for helping to put
small investments into the best of the
ideas coming through the summer
accelerator uh we've made our first
investment in a team just a few months
ago a team that came out of the school
of management actually and we're hopeful
to make another handful of investment
investments before the start of the
summer
so if you look at sort of the the
staging of the the activities that we
conduct now we go all the way from
very light touch of education
very small amount of education and skill
building through acceleration and into
investment
this whole process is only going to work
better
if we
have access to more alumni like yourself
so we're hopeful that um if you're
interested in what we're doing that
you'll you'll contact us either myself
or lean or any of my colleagues listed
here
none of these things would be possible i
just want to share with you the fact
that none of things would be possible
without the fact that we do have
partnerships across yale yei does not
live in isolation from the rest of the
university and for those of you who've
been away for either a few years or
maybe a few dozen years
the schools that some of you or that all
of you went to they're all beginning to
form their own innovation framework as
well and i list here just a small
handful of the schools that we work most
closely with in addition to yell college
obviously because these schools all work
their own processes and what yi tries to
do is to take the best of those projects
out of there and turn them where
appropriate into ventures
and first among the schools that really
deserves attention is the school of
management because um it's been our
closest partner uh since the beginning
and now with the the advent of having a
director of entrepreneurship and in the
person of kyle jensen who sits to my
right i think we're looking at a really
interesting time period at yale where
we're going to do a lot more things
together and kyle who's came to town
close to is it two years ago
three years ago kyle's been a very
important partner to yale even before
his his uh his rising to to the uh
entrepreneurship
chief at school of management he's been
a mentor an angel investor a very
skilled serial entrepreneur um has great
technical skills himself and we're we're
thrilled to come out here today and talk
to us about things that he's going to do
with som so with that i'm going to turn
the mic over to kyle
so as jim said obviously um
sounds like things have never been
better for entrepreneurship at slm right
there's
incredible enthusiasm for
entrepreneurship support for it that
transcends both students obviously the
alumni even here on the west coast
administration the faculty everyone's
interested in it
so
there is something we're missing though
right
what is missing
and that is an entrepreneurship
curriculum like before credit scholarly
study of entrepreneurship that
transcends disciplines
if you go to you go to cal here if you
go to stanford
go to mit so i might be issued at mit
there's 30 courses in entrepreneurship
at yale we have we have two three and
that's kind of broadly defined
entrepreneurship
well that should be a cause for an
introspection right it's an unusual
thing it's not something that we have
taught as a university
uh so a couple months ago barry nilbuff
who who you may know is a founder of
honesty he's an entrepreneur in his own
right he's a faculty person at school
management he got together with ted
snyder
and
peter and ben and they thought wow
can we teach entrepreneurship
uh and should is that something we
should do
and the answer was yes you can other
people do and
we should too
so i'm incredibly enthused to tell you
that
the
school of management is hiring a body of
faculty in the area of entrepreneurship
to teach entrepreneurship
to the ailes
i am the first person hired into that
program and i am the director of that
program and
i think that is the best job on the
planet
so so let me tell you let me tell you
what i'm working on and what we're doing
and the scale of the investment so my
life essentially has three priorities
now the first is building this
curriculum uh that curriculum
well i'll get into that first is
building the curriculum the second is
supporting in particular uh
founders at the school of management
okay we have not done a great job with
that in the past and the third is
working with yes and yeah and jim and uh
c-day innovate health all the people at
uh at yale who are interested in
entrepreneurship to contribute what i
can to an already strong community and
culture of entrepreneurship
i hope that i can make a meaningful
impact in that regard
as as
as you may know so jim and i are great
great friends uh you know we're attached
to the hip i i have this hat this
necklace it's a half heart he has the
other half
right so we're really working together
to do this
so i'm super excited about it so let me
tell you about some of the things in
particular that i i want to i want to
express you to the scale of this this
investment in this effort uh so around
the curricular piece okay so
as i said we would like to create a
curriculum for the scholarly study of
entrepreneurship for credit in the
classroom okay
that
curriculum will be available not only to
mba students but anybody on the campus
that includes yale college okay
uh and we're making a significant
investment in that regard so i
let me tell you about that just so you
can realize this is not vaporware so i
am the first full-time faculty hire
i have another full-time faculty hire i
have two part-time faculty already on
staff full-time deputy director
full-time admin assistant fantastic
space in this new evidence building that
you may have seen on campus right we
have this like garish glass cathedral to
management that's at the corner of
uh sachim and whitney you know a quarter
billion dollar building fantastic
beautiful space we have a big center in
there for supporting so i'm
entrepreneurs
uh and
here's the most special thing
um this is fantastic hearing all of this
when you look at the primary literature
around entrepreneurship pedagogy there's
very few things that are known so
there's there's there's not too much
social science to support how best to
teach entrepreneurship right and there's
different people have different
philosophies about it should it be
action-based should it be
lecture or what should it be
there is one exception to that and that
is that
exposure to experienced entrepreneurs in
your educational process
substantially increases the probability
that you yourself will become an
entrepreneur so
in addition to the positions that i
mentioned to you i have four
part-time visiting faculty slots that
will be filled by yale alumni
who are entrepreneurs to come back and
share their experiences
this is a big deal right these are
people who are incredibly experienced it
is important to get students in front of
those people so we have a number of
people lined up for the first year
i couldn't be more excited so some of
them you'll know and i'm sure they'll
resonate with you so for example elon
bombs who i know funded many of you is
the founder of launch capital uh you
know seed state investment firm on the
on the east coast uh elslm alumni uh he
will be teaching entrepreneurial finance
in the fall right it's gonna be
fantastic the thing i'm most excited
about uh is that in the spring uh miles
lasseter and miles we're already three
months right there founder of higher one
obviously you know a legend in his own
right miles and i will be teaching uh
management of software development in
the spring which is fantastic right so
those among you who are in the
technology space if you have lamented
that yale lacks a harvard cs50 and you
know we need to have more
entrepreneurship education this class is
absolutely perfect for that i couldn't
be more excited about it so
so this is to say that we essentially
are investing a great deal in the
curricular component at yale and i think
it will fundamentally change that we
will teach entrepreneurship there will
be many classes those classes will have
a diverse constituency comprising mba
students students from the sciences the
professional schools yale college it
will be fantastic and everybody is
committed to it so that's the first
piece second piece is that my mandate is
to support to the extent that i can
entrepreneurs particularly the school of
management i know there's many alumni in
the audience some of whom are
entrepreneurs and you probably felt at
the time
back in the day that we did not support
we did little to support entrepreneurs
at the school management
i have a tremendous amount of resources
to now
do that better including scholarships
including space including mentors
including and this is the best part we
have post-graduate fellowships for five
students next year they graduate with
mbas they will have their educational
loans deferred for two years and during
those two years if their startup
implodes or they have a kid or they
decide that entrepreneurship is tough
and emotionally challenging they can
return and recruit with the graduated
class right which is a big deal so it's
a really big deal so i can say to the
student with a straight face
i have limited for you your opportunity
cost associated with being an
entrepreneur
for god's sake do not take that goldman
john right
go do something
go do something bold and innovative with
your life right go ahead and change the
world right yale has a history of
contributing to to the united states to
the world and across sciences medicine
government society a large form a large
number of those contributions now are
done through entrepreneurs right
this is the kind of people we want to
generate so that's the second mandate
for me supporting som entrepreneurs in
particular now the third is to build a
culture of entrepreneurship as som in
particular but also to support jim and
yes and others
at building that across yale and this is
something i'm super excited about we
have a tremendous budget around building
culture and our thesis for building
culture is pretty simple that you have
events we bring back entrepreneurs we
talk about entrepreneurship we talk
about investing and we provide people
numerous opportunities for small
positive interactions uh
across disciplines we also preferably
feed them food and maybe some booze
right and this i think is how culture is
built right we need to do more of this
jim and i will do this in lockstep next
year and i'm tremendously excited about
it i need many of you to come back and
speak i think jim jim obviously feels
the same so please get in touch like
that tremendously
so this is essentially what we're doing
i think it's a bold plan it's a serious
investment it's very real here's how
real it is my budget for this program
increases
contractually 20 per year everyone
recognizes this is a priority
and i am honored to to be leading this
at the school of management
so that's essentially all i want to tell
you this morning and i will i will
conclude with a plea and that is
we're going to create this curriculum at
yale right and that curriculum should
not be the curriculum that i went
through in mit or the curriculum at
stanford or cal there are things that
make yale special right yale students
contribute not just by building like
snap track we can't just have a program
for that we need a program that teaches
them to be entrepreneurs in the private
sector in the public sector uh in the
nonprofit sector right there are things
that make
yale special and that should make our
entrepreneurship classes fit in with the
larger context of a liberal arts
education at yale
if you have opinions about that if you
have thoughts about what that should
look like
i am all ears i am in desperate need for
your council and would appreciate it
greatly so please do get in touch with
me because this is the time in which
we're trying to shape this and those of
you who've been through yale and know
most what should be there
i would like to hear from you so that's
all i have to say thank you